this weekend donald trump is going to be
speaking at a rally in arizona i will be
covering that rally one of the people
that is reportedly speaking alongside
donald trump at that rally is none other
than my pillow founder mike lindell
known to us as mike pillow lindell says
he's going to be one of the opening acts
at donald trump's january 15th rally in
arizona and expect 60 000 people to show
up why do i mention that well someone
who is going to be appearing alongside
the former president of the united
states is now claiming that he has
evidence to imprison
300 million americans for their actions
related to the 2020 election now you
might say wait david sir there are only
258 million adults in the us as of 2020.
and of the 258 million not all of them
not nearly all of them actually voted
doesn't matter pillow says he has
evidence to imprison 300 some million
people take a listen to what he had to
say this is the stuff of insanity
everything you're going to see over
these next seven months right get rid of
the machines you're going to see the
supreme court case coming out all these
great things everybody by the way you
can find more at frankspeach.com i'll
put that little i'll put that out there
there are so many i'm more optimistic
today than i have been yesterday the day
before that i'm on an incline like this
why because it's so amazing all the
things that we have we already have all
the pieces of the puzzle and you talk
about evidence we had enough evidence to
put everybody in prison for life for 300
and some million people uh wait we have
that all the way back to november
december he has the evidence to put 300
and some million people in prison for
life now before we get back to that if
you're wondering about that scratchy
weird voice that he has i will mention
that our friend zachary patrizo from the
daily beast reported about that
yesterday and says my pillow ceo mike
lindell
has come down with a severe case of
quote laryngitis
and he added in a comment to the daily
beast i can't get covid while citing his
consumption of an unproven covid19 drug
he probably has covid
is my understanding of that but more
importantly
evidence to imprison 300 something
million americans for life so if there's
only 258 million adults as of 2020 he's
talking about imprisoning
every adult who voted
every adult who didn't vote and then 42
million children
so things going
very very wrong for mike lindell in all
all senses of the word
likely has covid and again claims he
will be speaking at the trump rally this
weekend now i will be covering the trump
rally and many of you have written in
saying david please cover the trump
rally
others have said david don't cover the
trump rally
i'm going to cover the trump rally um it
is fascinating you know i
i just cover what is interesting and i
am fascinated to see
does the topic of vaccines come up at
the rally and does trump get booed trump
has been pushing the vaccines pretty
hard saying of course everybody needs
freedom but pretty significantly pushing
the vaccines is he going to get booed in
arizona for promoting the vaccines is
trump going to make an announcement
about 2024 is trump going to make any
announcements about support for
candidates in 2022 is mike lindell
really allowed to go and speak alongside
the former president given that he
almost certainly has coveted right now
uh and also is completely out of his
mind and it's humiliating that he's even
allowed near the president i mean it's
all completely crazy so i will be
covering the rally if it's not
interesting to you just don't watch it
um that that's my recommendation but i
will be live on
youtube
twitch
and facebook starting at 8 p.m eastern
saturday
trump expected to speak at 9 00 pm
meaning he will likely speak between
10 p.m and midnight i don't know he's
always historically he's always insanely
late to his speaking engagement so
that's going to be this weekend in the
meantime uh
we have no idea
what sort of evidence mike pillow claims
to have but i would guess that you and i
would not find it particularly
compelling make sure you're following me
on twitter at d pacman remember that we
are
still banned from facebook monetization
we're like five days into our 90 day ban
for what facebook's
algorithm misidentified as anti-vaccine
content from us laughable claim
you all know
that we
are pro-vaccine because that's what the
science points to and we were reporting
on anti-vaxx alex jones and we have been
banned from facebook monetization for 90
days you can uh support us in that uh in
fighting that endeavor by signing up at
joinpakman.com and using the coupon code
f facebook that's facebook with two fs f
facebook you tell me what it means we'll
take a break we have a fantastic program
for you today glad you're with us
even if like me you're not vegan and
you're not vegetarian
eating a more plant-based diet is a
really great thing to do for a number of
different reasons and our sponsor just
egg is the delicious plant-based egg you
can use it anywhere you use traditional
eggs because the taste and texture are
identical but just eggplant-based eggs
have the same amount of protein as
traditional eggs i use it all the time
at home you can make fluffy scrambled
eggs you can make omelets you can make
quiche frittata crepes fried rice you
should see my fried rice recipe you can
really use it anywhere in baking or
anywhere you would use traditional eggs
when i first tried just egg
i was surprised that a plant-based egg
could both taste and cook just like
traditional eggs you can get it at the
grocery store instacart amazon go try it
eating a more plant-based diet is a
great decision i do it and i'm not vegan
or vegetarian and just egg makes it that
much more easy and delicious